ce sont des accusations lourdes porté
par amnesty international dans un
rapport publié ce jeudi selon angie
affirme que l'ukraine aurait risqué la
vie de nombreux civils depuis le début
de l'invasion russe selon les enquêteurs
dépêchés dans les régions du sud et de
l'est du pays l'armée ukrainienne aurait
établi des bases dans des écoles et des
hôpitaux et lancer des attaques depuis
des zones résidentielles des pratiques
contraires au droit international
d'après la secrétaire générale d'amnesty
nous avons documenté une tendance des
forces je craignais à mettre en danger
les civils et à violer les lois de la
guerre lorsqu'elles opèrent dans des
zones peuplées le fait de se trouver
dans une position de défense ne dispense
pas l'armée ukrainienne de respecter le
droit international humanitaire
amnesty international ajoute que c'est
tactique ne justifie pas l'invasion
russe une nuance qui ne satisfait pas
les autorités ukrainiennes dans son
allocution quotidienne volodymyr joly a
critiqué les conclusions de l'omg
comme celle de tchoyi this is in show il
n'y a pas de rapports clairs de
certaines organisations internationales
sur les crimes commis par des
terroristes russes
mais aujourd'hui nous avons vu un
rapport complètement différent d'amnesty
international qui tente malheureusement
d'amnistié l'état terroriste et de
transférer la responsabilité de
l'agresseur à la victime
la chaire en juin dernier amnesty
international avait accusé la russie de
crimes de guerre pour ses frappes menées
sur des cibles civiles